using what we found in Google Trends you
can further explore key word options
using Google Keyword planner keyword
planner is an awesome tool that's
similar to Google Trends in some ways
like identifying related keywords and
seeing historical statistics but the
biggest difference is we get to narrow
down options by their performance and
what we can afford this will help us
make our plan more realistic and will
support our decision about keywords and
budget when we build our AdWords
campaign now the biggest takeaways for
keyword planner are first
expanding your keyword options based on
your first set of keywords from Google
Trends you can get ideas to more
relevant keywords and hopefully ones you
actually haven't thought of before
second you can use it as a simulation
for different bids budgets and learn
what estimated number of clicks and
conversions you might get from certain
keywords this will help you choose your
bid on every keyword and plan your
budget accordingly for your AdWords
campaign however if your keywords are
really popular among advertisers it
might be challenging and expensive for
you to bid on clicks we'll learn more in
Lesson four about how your placement in
a search results list is a combination
of your performance and your bid now as
a beginner it's usually pretty tricky
for you it'll take you a while to
perform better than the existing players
especially if it's a crowded market like
insurance for example and obviously your
advertising budget is going to be a
little bit lower than those big-name
advertisers make sure you're focusing on
keywords that are really specific for
your added value that way you'll perform
better than your competitors and have
fewer competitors for us for example we
learned that in Google Trends pet care
is a more popular search term than Pet
Sitting so we may want to go with that
search term and reach a bigger audience
however the truth of the matter is then
we would be competing with veterinarian
services insurance for pets and other
advertisers who have a much larger
budget than we do at abarkment
so rather than having us walk through
Google's keyword planner with you we
highly encourage you to check out
Google's documentation it's really
wonderful for people of all skill sets
so if you're an expert at keyword
planner or just starting out
the documentation is really easy and
engaging there's a link to a video in
the instructor notes that talks more
about keyword planner as well as a link
to the documentation this documentation
will be endlessly helpful for you when
you're exploring keywords and other
Google tools it's great practice to get
comfortable exploring documentation
because technology is ever-changing